[Applaudissements]
alors voilà d'ordre animaux dont je vais
souvent au zoo avec mes enfants
quel est votre animal préféré maxime
j'adore le tigre du bengale il a le
charme
bon moi c'est l'éléphant et l'éléphant
se radine pardon vous coupez vous nous
faites peur la regarder tout cela n'est
qu'une usine est si vous télé alors
l'éléphant pourquoi je laime
particulièrement ses patrons n'ont
évidemment pas la seule à cause de ses
dents parce qu'il produit
il produit beaucoup de tartre we all
d'accord donc moi j'ai créé avec mes
enfants
donc un truc que je ne fais qu avec mes
enfants un dentifrice spéciale pour
éléphant dont il se défend
alors ça s'appelle à merveille un hélène
meyer à col de cygne que je les mette
d'abord ce premier produit délicatement
attention il y avait les n'y a pas
d'explosion bien d'accord taris bernard
oui je te plaît mettez lui n'est jamais
vraiment pas chez nous
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
très belle couleur un peu violette
correa s'est alors c'est un dentifrice à
un peu liquide ouais ok donc je vais
prendre la dernière solution
on va savourer un médiateur partir ils
suivent à sortir un thème on fait comme
bon alors voilà au [ __ ]
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
vous n'avez un peu sur le visage est
alors venu de nis ben ali mais sauf que
sa magie de la magie chimie qui a laissé
couler mais voilà et sakho ni hoarau ni
combien ces coupes à voile à toi faut
montrer que ça car on le voyait aller
alerter
voilà ce sera les pour me geraldine a
assuré et une expérience m'a gonflé le
dantesque bourrel et france a eu besoin
de moi je trouve ça magique campus est
trop jolie c'est les couleurs de
l'arc-en-ciel moi je trouve ça génial